gráfica este sistema de ecuaciones e
identifica el número de soluciones que
tiene y aquí nos dan un sistema de
ecuaciones el cual tenemos que graficar
y pensar acerca de sus soluciones
esta primera ecuación la voy a
reescribir nuevamente en el mismo color
en la que lo voy a graficar ya está en
la forma pendiente ordenada ye igual a 3
x + 1 podemos ver entonces que la
pendiente es igual a 3 y la ordenada el
origen la ordenada es igual a 1 esta es
la pendiente la llamado m pues en muchos
textos la ecuación de la recta le
escriben como ye igual a mx + b vamos a
graficar la la ordenada al origen es el
punto 01 vamos a ubicarlo 0,1 aquí
tenemos el eje ye y éste aquí es el eje
x y ahora la pendiente es igual a 3
quiere decir que si nos movemos en 1 en
la dirección positiva de las equis vamos
a movernos en 3 hacia arriba si
avanzamos 2 hacia la derecha vamos a
subir
a 2 466 / 2 es igual a 3 se conserva el
valor de la pendiente lo mismo pasaría
si nos movemos en 1 en la dirección
negativa de x nos moveríamos 3 en la
dirección negativa de iu menos 3 entre
menos 1 sigue siendo igual a 3 si nos
movemos menos 2 en x nos moveremos menos
1 2 3 4 5 6 ahora podemos unir los
puntos para tener la gráfica de esta
recta unimos estos puntos lo voy a hacer
lo mejor posible aquí tenemos la recta
no no está muy recta déjame hacerla
mejor
aquí tenemos unimos los puntos y no sé
qué pasó y mi mano está muy temblorosa
vamos a intentarlo nuestro mejor intento
último intento ahí la tenemos no está
tan mal
este es esta recta igual a 3 x 1 graphic
hemos ahora la segunda ecuación la
segunda ecuación labor de escribir aquí
4 igual a 6x y la quiero llevar a la
forma pendiente ordenada a la forma
igual a mx más b para esto lo que
hacemos es vamos a restarle 4 a ambos
lados de la ecuación así es que estamos
4 del lado izquierdo y restamos 4 del
lado derecho el lado izquierdo nos queda
2 que es igual a 6 x menos 4 ahora para
despejar y vamos a dividir entre 2 ambos
lados de la ecuación dividimos entonces
entre 2 el lado izquierdo y entre 2 2
términos del lado derecho
ahora la ecuación resulta que igual a 3
x menos 2 que igual a 3 x menos 2 y ya
tenemos esta segunda ecuación en la
forma pendiente ordenada graphic hemos
ahora esta recta tenemos una ordenada al
origen de menos 2 ubicamos el punto cero
coma menos 2 y la pendiente es 3 observa
que es la misma pendiente de aquí tiene
la misma inclinación estas dos rectas si
avanzamos 1 a la derecha subimos 3
avanzamos 1 a la derecha subimos otros 3
avanzamos
a la derecha subimos tres y lo mismo si
nos vamos hacia la izquierda uno a la
izquierda tres abajo uno a la izquierda
tres abajo aquí tenemos algunos puntos
de la segunda recta unimos estos puntos
para obtener la recta voy a hacerlo lo
mejor posible para que sea recta ya la
tenemos ahí tenemos esa segunda recta la
cual llevamos primero a su forma punto
pendiente y luego la gráfica mos ahora
hicimos todo esto para identificar el
número de soluciones que tiene este
sistema de ecuaciones pero la solución
de un sistema de ecuaciones es una
pareja de valores xy que satisfacen
ambas ecuaciones ahora si hubiera un
valor de xy que cumpliera con este
sistema de ecuaciones entonces ese valor
de xy tendría que ubicarse en las dos
gráficas pues esta recta en azul son
todas las parejas de xy que cumplen con
esta primera ecuación la recta roja son
todas las parejas xy que cumplen con la
segunda ecuación si una pareja cumple
con ambas ecuaciones tiene que ubicarse
en las dos rectas pero al ver las
gráficas vemos que son dos rectas
paralelas dos rectas que nunca se
intersectan no existe un punto de
intersección no hay una
qué valores exige que cumpla con ambas
ecuaciones entonces no se intersectan no
intersección
por lo tanto no hay solución a este
sistema de ecuaciones
esto implica entonces que no hay
solución no solución sabemos eso porque
estas dos rectas no se intersecta y
quizá no necesitas graficar para saber
eso te están dando dos rectas distintas
pues tienes dos coordenadas al origen
distintas sin embargo tienen la misma
pendiente son rectas paralelas son
rectas que nunca se intersecta y como
esas rectas son la representación
gráfica de cada una de las ecuaciones
del sistema el sistema no tiene solución